[Musik]
viel spaß die hin und weg wünscht de
erhält können
los geht's was sie eigentlich leben lang
und oft nicht ganz so
falsch wäre das war nicht das schweizer
magazin
gesetzt für zukunfts also wetter schweiz
china
golo es gibt fragen die würden ihn am
liebsten stehe ich muss wachsam sein
meine antennen sind immer ausgefahren
[Musik]
der ecuadorianische pazifik küste lebt
offenbar begehrt zu tun zusammen mit der
angie und deren ihrer tochter galina
haben wir beruhigen das könnte news mehr
und dadurch dass das gros vom meer hat
damit den anschein dass wo mich
fasziniert
wir helfen ihnen das blut rein zu
bringen
uns kommt her wir brauchen eure mekies
und
prinz
ich kaufe krediten für ein feines essen
lebt ja noch
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
sid
[Musik]
woher weiß das nicht fehlen
was kosten
es war eine freude mit ihnen zu
geschäften grad wert
[Musik]
direkt
folgen sie mir bitte was kostet die
nacht 25 dollar das ist das letzte freie
[Musik]
stadt vermögen vor ihrer 100 verwalten
der ehemalige banker eigene geld knapp
und wie das hotel investiert
ein liter bitte
danke oder einen schönen tag live als
auch
hier via bittorrent und im prinzip also
die besucher zum einfach und dann eine
hilfe wie und dass sie haben das hotel
überwiegend findet ihr schon seit jahren
steht
das datum allein schaffen ich ich sollte
vorwoche
die strecke
da im tiroler nachteilig da macht er
einfach da
von zeugen was den grad der macht
[Musik]
guten morgen
schreibst du heute für mich
von beiden 2
[Musik]
danke pass auf dich auf
die scouts für ihren im prinzip ganz
hartes spiel für die unternehmen ja aber
sagen
aber ich wünsche ihm viel glück gehabt
haben und macht die hohle hand im
prinzip über eine webseite macht es uns
dann schon
losgehen
[Musik]
der coiffeur ist im zentrum vom dorf
canoa sind überrascht und sitzt am tisch
oder
auch wenn es schon nicht gefällt am
wochenende will ich mich zurecht machen
alle männer wollen eine herausgeputzte
und doch schlichte frau
außerdem sollten nicht anderen frauen
nach
wenn eine anschmachtet dann reagiere ich
muss man
sich
oft ist es so wenn die frauen einen
ausländer sehen respektieren sie nicht
dass er schon vergeben ist
dann markiere ich elegant dass er mir
gehört küssen und umarmen
das heißt für mich mein revier abstecken
doch immer im trend
[Musik]
das bleibt jetzt
perfekt gestylt und bereit sich in jede
hose voll bricht stelle gott
patchworkfamilie im ausgang der
samstägige china hi-tech gehört nun mal
in 3
[Musik]
einzig die beiden uwe dating-plattform
keine glühlampen zu feiern pck sie trio
letztendlich zähle als familie
[Musik]
das gerade um stellt das lied als kurz
nach zehn minuten
führt andrea schütz der große moment
schluss mit der fernbeziehung der petro
ihre liebe aus venezuela und da und
endlich darf auch liebe
für der wichtige tag ist auch iris große
neigung zum flughafen
kommen ist die hannoversche verändert
wie damit besonders hätte jetzt ab jetzt
sie sind ja andere kleider gefordert
vereinskasse selbst bestellt um das
wohnhaus über
außerdem sind short als ja
haben wir jetzt
[Musik]
ja alles gut alles gut
ich kann es kaum glauben
ist das alles ja
doch
ich habe hunger
nach einer schier endlose papier projekt
hätte pedro endlich hoch zum
willkommen
schuhe ausziehen ich habe geputzt
soll ich jetzt was kochen
[Musik]
und wo sind die essiggurken
es klingt komisch aber wir müssen uns
erst daran gewöhnen täglich zusammen zu
sein
viele veränderungen aber gute
veränderungen
und du bekommst nun gutes essen der
glückspilz
[Musik]
vor dem tod
wenn meine arbeit es verlangen würde in
die schweiz zurückzukehren dann würden
wir das genau anschauen
ich denke du könntest es dir
grundsätzlich vorstellen in der schweiz
zu legen trend gibt viele dinge die du
magst vieles dass du nicht magst aber
das ist in china genauso
ja ich bin jemand der sich schnell an
einem neuen ort zurechtfinden kann
[Musik]
sich neu zurechtfinden hat sich alte
matthias müller
von der ostschweiz frieder reusch zu
schaffen richtig heimisch fühlt er sich
erst seit jahren gefunden und mit ihrer
klinik jenson überholt
[Musik]
und bleibt wie in the big challenge war
worden ist sie unterstützt familie wo
sie
hiesige kilometer weg gibt es neues
anderes marie-elisabeth
[Musik]
ja
ja ja
mit dem
schlaf
[Musik]
ep extrem dankbar dass sie heute das
workout und er seinen zynischen aber
egal wie viel er
in und
ausland jetzt mit jonas die 61
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
schlecht
weg der riesige distanz möglich machen
strom häufiger pflege zu bändigen schied
besonders sorgfältig das ist ein
weihnachtsgeschenk für deinen getty
er ist im richtigen alter die füße haben
die geeignete größe
[Musik]
hast du gesehen wie den c hochgezogen
hatte ich mach nicht mit
so unterschiedlich der sharon und der
matthias ihre herkunft aus simaks bei
die händen starke familie sich vor einer
klage sie dass sie auch selber reinigen
klingt mein langes sind planen und
versucht zur gmbh und dann wirklich noch
bei jahres in kraft
und hier haben wir sind megastolz zu
finden und mit dieser hat so wie sie
familie vergrößern jetzt nach marika das
frei ist aber
definitiv noch vieles familie ist sehr
sehr wichtig
alles ist in gottes händen
und man kann das nicht richtig planen
wir aber es wäre mein wunsch ja dass er
einen bruder oder eine schwester
bekommen
[Musik]
da sind
das ist für dich nie
[Musik]
in einem jahr da möchte ich deutsch
sprechen können
ja ja wo ich den job einen job haben und
sie wäre vielleicht schwanger
[Musik]
endlich und gemeinsamer alltag aber
rooney drosch andrea und pedro weiters
venezuela der schweiz zwei mal eben
darum soll ihre liebe offiziell werden
in einer woche erwartet
vielleicht
werde ich ja
weil es dann für sie reden wollen wir
auch trainer anschauen
[Musik]
wird andrea darf das ruhiger bis guten
konventionell los am wichtigsten ist
peter pries für die and marketing
fachfrau andreas geld für beide
hast du verstanden
das sind die preiswerteren
eigentlich wolltest du keine ringe und
jetzt willst du doch warum hast du die
meinung geändert
ich weiß es nicht
schwierig zu sagen
vielleicht viel zu einfach richtig mit
ihr hering zu groß
glänzt er nicht zu stark
wir müssen uns entscheiden
wir können in den ring auch um den hals
tragen ja
der erste chrome promis sind neue leber
herz erfolgreiches gefunden
[Musik]
dann nehmen wir beides
von herz dann musst du einfach zu allem
ja sagen
eines morgens wir hatten das hotel
gerade übernommen da kamen um 5 uhr in
der frühe gäste die wollten sofort ein
zimmer haben
da wurde richtig
ich sagte zu ihm beruhige dich wenn du
dich nicht sofort beruhigt gehen
so läuft das hier nicht
man muss ruhig und liebenswürdig sein du
darfst nicht ausflippen
[Musik]
zweimal im monat fahren grünstadt man
dort familie von je 100 kilometer
ein leben lang habe ich mir meine
familie zusammengelebt
in unmittelbarer nähe leben meine
cousinen tanten onkel meine geschwister
einfach alle
[Musik]
wenigen aufforderung vom rollator
warum er jetzt division alcon
chöre sie offen und der vertrauen
verdienen und so
fortfahren
kann diese einfachen verhältnissen
aufgewachsen
ihre eltern sind vom lamm die stadt zog
viel krampf wird und sie schließlich in
ruhiger gegen format dieses muss keine
leichte
bis frühjahr hätten
[Musik]
hallo
angie hat 52 für eine breitere ende
behinderung und wohne bild
wie ist es euch ergangen sehr gut und
die
seele von der familie ist olga orange
schwarz blind
hat viel auf die klinik liter aufpasst
und anziehen auf der gemeindeverwaltung
schafstädt
[Musik]
der vater von kirche ist der ruhige pol
der familie
es ist schon fast tradition dass es
schwingt hof zum zmittag liegt wenn der
ton kommt
queens raubfisch günstig und der
delikatesse zumindest für familie voran
und mustern zu verbissen und der ist
zwar hat rational und sozusagen im
prinzip
für den turm gibt es nur nach
fritzlar mit kaufen
kunst von der schwiegermutter kühne ich
wichtig sie für der turm
es war für mich schon ein schlag als er
mich fragte aber angie mitnehmen dürfe
sagte ich zu ihm du hast ihn jedoch
schon lange weg genommen
für meine tochter ist gut für mich wäre
nichts
vergaberecht angie im hinteren teil von
grundstückseigentum trainer bauer
das ist mein haus er wohl hoch wie mit
bad und dusche und im oberen stock zwei
zimmer
ich habe beim bau mitgeholfen
die leiter rauf und runter hb zement
gerührt gemalt
und doch das haus hat mich meine ganzen
ersparnisse gekostet als später wegen
des erdbebens der obere stock wieder
zusammen viel half mir dann tom diesen
neu aufzubauen
als alleinerziehende mutter ist sie froh
dass sie damit ihre familie wohne
habe ich so viele erinnerungen und so
viel arbeit
der leibliche vater
dann gehe ich ganz oft hilfe der
familien
in den schlimmsten momenten meines
lebens haben sie mir immer geholfen mein
bruder
alle sind mir bei gestanden
meine mutter
[Musik]
das war unser zimmer als dann tom
hierher gekommen ist
[Musik]
geburtstag kurz zur sache
wenn er noch blutig will sich ohnmächtig
werden
ja das weiß ich und wenn ich ein huhn
schlachte dann gefällt ihm das gar nicht
ich denke das macht ihm halt angst
wir frauen sind härter im nehmen
stimmt doch das sehe ich bei uns zu
hause mein ehemann sagt zu allem nein
und ich sage dann erst recht ja so läuft
der hase
olga ich nun mit 10 2 klatsche für die
familie
dank ihr ist eric stolle die mutter hat
sie ihre volk lebt wo ist die zunge
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
und so wie ich es für beruhigende
nachricht dank
kontrabass
und
das
[Musik]
frühstück fahne ist der kopf butterweich
geschmort dazu die wurzel
für mich eine kleine portion
guten appetit
nein nicht reisen pool er reist mit
schwein
reis mit
[Musik]
mir schmeckt aber ich könnte nicht sagen
dass ich dafür sehr weit gehen würde
meine lieblingsspeise ist es nicht
[Gelächter]
es war wieder sehr schön bei euch danke
hier ist es wirklich schön es ist toll
venezuela oder tweets wenn's hoch
zitiert wird hektisch
der kollegin mit schleier für frisuren
übernimmt ein wichtiger tag drohne
fotograf ist
da ohne sie
wird
das letzte mal haben wir solide
termin
hallo
bis spät ran.de haben sie dich
verunstaltet
mich sehen
ist zufrieden es
ist okay
leider hatte die frau keine große
erfahrung mit burton so musste ich ihr
alles erklären
ich musste mich selber frisieren
ich war ein wenig irritiert aber was
soll's
heute ist der große tag nicht kann mir
die freude nehmen
wir haben die bürste gesucht
ja wo ist die dünne schwarze
dem büro im büro da habe ich gesucht
umsonst
sieht wird immer knapper die zwei
stunden meisten aus hochzeitskleid sieht
beim fang trauriger
[Musik]
was dort aus neues update
vielleicht mehr für den aus für mich
heißen türkei
[Musik]
weckte lebe ich bring it on the youth
montana und jörg folgt irgendwann aber
wen auch immer dichtere so stark wurde
dass sie hat mir sitzung
[Musik]
jay ist sofort klar sie jetzt ich sah
ihn time 12 schließlich könne sie bei
die zeit und das obwohl anonym außerhalb
der usa
[Musik]
dann gibt es keine
ich muss noch lernen
da gibt es drei
so wie geht es euch
also etwa acht oder neun jahre alt war
habe ich statt deinen hund hühner als
erwachsener im reservat hatte ich
während 15 jahren hühner
wir haben immer dafür gebetet dass wir
hier lüner und garten einen eigenen ort
haben werden das alles haben wir nun
wo immer wir hingehen wir bringen es zum
laufen
die beide sind durch schwierige zeiten
bei die sind doch leipzig vor fünf
minuten
gestartet tumor entfernt
vor kurzem hat dort noch untersucht
ich habe gute neuigkeiten ich muss keine
chemie machen
sie fanden jedoch einen knoten in wollen
sie nun genauer untersuchen
ich hoffe dass ich bald krebsfrei bin
meine wunderbare frau
ihr krebs hat mich viel mehr beunruhigt
das meine ich will sie nicht verlieren
sie ist mein leben
die beide sind im big creator im großen
schöpfer dankbar komm zu uns erahnen
hört unsere gebete schöpfer wir danken
dir für all die guten dinge die du uns
gegeben hast ein heim das essen gute
freunde
meine frau
der mutige schwarze adler gesprochen
er hat gesprochen
zwar gibt es unter james lebens mit all
seinen möglichkeiten
ich habe einen abschluss so genannter
medizinmann
in meinem buch möchte ich eine
verbindung schaffen zwischen den active
americans der westlichen welt
damit wir uns alle besser verstehen
können
[Musik]
meine königin
[Gelächter]
oh ja
gründer hier mit den
familien es ist ja
eine einzige erwartungen sie ist mit ihr
zusammen sein zu können und zwar in
diesem dem nächsten und übernächsten
leben
der schöpfer exit zum sterben sondern
zum leben braucht vor dem sind beide
überzeugt mit der zuversicht los geht's
die zukunft
es ist traurig dass meine eltern nicht
dabei sein können
wäre pedro sind die ältere ist venezuela
unmöglich sie innert nützlicher frist
ein gültiger pass über zwei zu mitglieds
reise
ich hab dir schon verlassen
[Musik]
sie haben sich entschlossen
miteinander de einzugehen in den
weiteren lebensweg von jetzt an alle
leute zu beschreiten sie wirklich denn
sich gegenseitig das wohl der
gemeinschaft in einträchtiger im
zusammenwirken zu wahren und für die
kinder gemeinsam zu machen
sich ineinander und leichter sie
sachlich anderen können sie selber
machen
standen
nicht wenn sie frauen reagierten peter
otto kratie sanchez die hier eingehen
dann antworten sie ja ja
und möchte sie später sogar die sanchez
mit claudia götz die eingehen dann
antworten sie mit ja
dass die preise meine frage mit ja
beantwortet haben durch ihre gemeinsame
bestimmung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
lassen
der petro ich nur in herzform andrea
ihre familien in dem mit offenen armen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
schön
[Musik]
überhaupt sieht das cover seines lebens
paris aber
was ich brauche ist ein großer beweis
was mir selbst wenn gm in libyen
bestätigt
na ja das wird morgen der schock sei im
prinzip habe ich sag das mal
der ton
bleibt es beim sachen aber aus der
schweiz mitgebracht
darunter auch freude velotouren
promotors canoa nödl so klemmt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
daher im
prinzip
ja
marco velo tour ist im lot
[Musik]
wir sind unterwegs zur reserve serie
andere ecuadorianische bierbrauerei
[Musik]
die vorwärts
fisch ist okay
[Musik]
meine güte was wäre ein weg
ein richtiges abenteuer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der turm und dann die beide träger
verantwortlich für carlita führer das
hotel sind jeden tag am rampe und gleich
wird sie immer noch frisch verliebt
die beide lebe die dritte patenschaft
trotz aller romantik 10
potter-fans dass irgendwann
eine hochzeit in weiß wann er ein traum
von mir wirklich
nicht verheiratet zu sein raubt mir
nicht den schlaf ich bin glücklich in
meiner situation
ich bin mit meiner realität ich bin mit
ihm den mann den ich liebe ich habe eine
tolle arbeit was will ich mehr
sie ist die frau meines lebens
ich liebe und schätze ihn sehr ich weiß
wird mich nie im stich lassen
das ist fast zu viel für mich
du bist das geschenk für mich
[Musik]
ich liebe dich sehr mein schöner
schweizer
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
das gab es noch nie vorgekommen dass ich
ein bisschen schönstein passieren
[Musik]
lerby nimmt nötig oder einfach stimmig
umso schöner wenn menschen trotzdem
miteinander
wenn die ich liebe auch einen ort
verschlagen wo du eigentlich nur für
möglich teilte
mit ich bin gespannt
[Musik]
gehen und ich präsentiert wurde von dr